[Music]
in conspiracy conspiracy
submitted by Joe Mallya is in Dubai
really is in Dubai it already exists I
didn't know that when I think of what
Joe Mallya would look like I feel like
it would look like Dubai really really I
pictured it like one of those like
deserted island kind of link in the
comments that leafy though is Italy
floors a barren and dry there's parts
that are very very leafy in their parts
are very very dry but there's beautiful
beaches everywhere although you're so
nice I just think Mad Max world you
you're alright you're alright but it's
in different eras definitely alright
that's deep yeah the sudden evacuation
of a solar observatory has sparked
conspiracy theories what's a solar
observatory um same your [ __ ] look at
the Sun and burn your eye is I think
Observatory like that yeah so those are
observed so like the Griffith
Observatory they observed the entire
space like okay
universe is solar system all that's left
but solar observatories they only look
at the Sun that's why everybody got
burnt ass eyes and got blind and that is
really sketchy though if there was like
an observatory that was for like looking
at the Sun suddenly it was an evacuation
that means that there's something the
government doesn't want us to see
there's a shit-ton conspiracy theory so
this whole thing let me throw me because
it's really juicy oh I think you're
gonna love it okay this Solar
Observatory it's in the mountains of New
Mexico and after 10 days it has now
reopened it was suddenly evacuated
because there was a mysterious security
threat that they won't elaborate on the
FBI was involved there was a Blackhawk
that was seen flying over the
observatory the fousey calling a bomb
that again
[Laughter]
it's a mysterious threat I don't I'm
just who is a youtuber trying to get
[ __ ] beauty of this Observatory it's
like on a really tall mountain right it
oversees like some of these theories
what they're saying is that it oversees
these two very secretive bases like
military bases so that might be a factor
into why that particular solar solar
observatory was closed there was this
other thing that right before it closed
they saw this very circular object cover
like passed by the Sun we're like oh my
god it was a spaceship but people are
like now come down that's just our moon
nothing to worry about that but there
was this other thing that they were
saying that around that same time I
think it was like about six webcams
around the world different all over the
world that were all of a sudden shut
down webcams like camp girls and [ __ ] no
lamer is that are looking at the
movements oh yeah yeah yeah what's going
on they were all pointed toward the Sun
and they blacked it out cuz we were like
six with webcams until I there were in
the middle of a strip show and if they
all blacked out at the same yes it was
just webcams pointed at the Sun right or
like in space somewhere like it's
usually that they're always running 24/7
vehicular one it was it just all of a
sudden the streaming stopped they're
just saying that goes the security
threat but they will not elaborate in
the fact that local police were kept in
the dark is also really fishy what if it
was like a solar flare oh it happened at
the observatory
yeah but then is that so a lot of people
are saying that - like what if they saw
something like aliens or something then
BOOM wouldn't all the observatories be
closed like why just this one cuz just
fish it they shut it down just that one
evacuated it Lisa no yeah local police
they keep them it feels like it's like a
top-secret thing where it's like these
guys are way too they don't have the
paid right to know this seems like it
all adds up to and then there's the six
webcams it's cuz there was a rat
infestation and had to call the [ __ ]
and they were embarrassed
they didn't want the local police to
think that their town is gonna [ __ ] yeah
I get it
it could be like really special like
insurgent rats that came through Isis
rats yeah so they had to like that's why
they brought in the FBI till I get these
damn they were illegal rats from the
Middle East you know what I think it was
it was a [ __ ] gray and which ones
inventory that that's the charging base
for electronic toothbrush mine looks
like a screenshot of drone footage I was
taken after it like when they shut it
down and then this was like this one
single wow that's a weird place to put a
stop sign mm-hmm yeah this is like all
we had just oh they moved to stop sign
to the middle yeah why they making
children's hide though oh I thought they
had okay I don't know I'm not only that
they say conspiracy theorists any
conspiracy theorists but I got a brain
now what does your brain tell you you
don't know why that one Observatory was
closed down only six webcams out of the
200 they're focused on the Sun why
because it was the angle it was the
angle of that area of the Sun there's
something that you could see that the
government doesn't want us to see
perhaps it's a glitch Oh bleach in the
matrix we don't what do they say they're
not saying anything what are the
conspiracy theories or the conspiracy
theory well yeah that's they aren't
talking about aliens like I can't wait
to engines there's a [ __ ] part on
this [ __ ] they got the truth
this is venom black in real life that's
the Menem that's the base you know if
there's any bald teenage girls that ran
out of there looking for the bloody nose
and waffles yeah that loves waffles and
some random kid lost on a bike in there
for
I want to know you know what the upside
down is is there a toothless boy with
curly hair that's running around riding
around the bicycle and only the front
are missing for some reason and they
like to play board games do they do they
have any theories on my way yeah do that
what do that fear is like they just like
it's me moment the $8 aliens or the
government's hiding it or I mean from
what I've seen the ones I've just told
you or other ones I've seen so it's like
the whole thing about like it's aliens
they saw something that you shouldn't
have captured they're shutting it down
to make oh I forgot to mention too they
also shut down the local postal office
cuz they don't want no letters to be
sent yeah they're saying like they don't
want any proof to be sent out the alien
sends a letter to the postal service yes
okay but it's just I'm so confused
because it's like usually when you hear
like assassination of JFK right
immediately you could be like oh yeah it
was probably the Mafia was probably this
or whatever in this case I'm just like
why would they shut that down I'm still
left with questions
yup why is the FBI getting involved in a
[ __ ] observatory this is not a theory
I didn't tell you about was that there
were foreign agents possibly Russian or
Chinese that had hacks the equipment in
order to maybe spy on the nearby
remember I said there's two secret bases
one of them is the nuclear missile range
and so maybe - oh that makes sense what
they would but what I don't understand
is the helicopter why would they need a
circle around you know like that that's
like usually they're looking for people
or they're making sure that the
perimeter is safe or what if something
dropped in that area just like area 51
from the Sun that's right Joe how did
you even play zelda before mm-hmm yeah I
forgot though yeah there's some parts
would like the Triforce it drops out of
the Sun and like some crazy [ __ ] like
that you don't believe in aliens yeah
course I do but I wouldn't I just don't
understand why the government would
cover it up and why they only go for
Rekluse white people that's the that's I
just don't understand why do they only
probe the butt
of hillbilly maybe they maybe it's not
that it's only them it's just that
they're the only ones that are vocal
about it I want to see a [ __ ] from copy
come out about like they don't know
crazy Wow it's always the hillbilly
though I like I still you know how like
you guys have like memories from when
you're a kid that like traumatized you
mine was like there I was watchin this
TV show one time and it had like the
creepy like spooky like like you know
music like like well just like real
spooky and it was about aliens and it
was this like old farm lady and she was
like I had a bunch of cows in one day
there was a lien strapped down these
very tiny tiny needle and they said all
the blood out of my cows and they were
just all outside flat that's what she
said happen and I believed it as a child
now I think that woman might have been
crazy but because of that I believe in
aliens and they have high-tech equipment
and they want to kill us all how come
there's never any Latinas from East LA
talking about aliens but no one wants to
sound crazy these are not scared of
sounding crazy so they're just God yeah
that's that's true I think everyone's
gonna sound crazy no Billy's are the
only ones that aren't afraid to sound
crazy I feel like there's a handful of
people have you seen the news girl have
you seen have you seen Latinas on the
news Florida men talking about aliens
cuz you know Florida Florida out of
control they they really they out here
maybe there's too much humidity for the
alien aircraft to land properly there oh
yeah like fall into it we really have to
have the perfect factors how about a
Chinese cook in the Midwest huh hmm you
never see him going goddamn there's an
alien in my back hole might be I could
see it maybe they just don't get
publicized I would like to see that one
day on ancient aliens I've never seen
that is that a joke yeah it's like the
best show ever
no there's so much evidence pointing to
alien involvement it's dope like
starting in the B C's I can't watch
anything about aliens I'm terrified like
the ultimate prank would be to break
into my house dress as an alien and I
would probably laugh
own throat how do you feel about that
theory that weird the aliens I mean
technically we are to the other aliens
but I mean like that where we came from
another planet and we're here on earth
we do look weird
heythis like space just freaks me now
actually what I think I think we're
listening to all the theories out there
I feel like we're an engineered slave
race that's one of the Sumerian texts
say yeah because we're really similar to
dolphins and are really similar to some
other primates but those two animals
have nothing in common
and we're the only ones that can
communicate on this earth which is
really weird and there's a old like
Sumerian texts that talk about kind of
like the Noah's Ark concept of
collecting DNA of animals and already
like having genetic modification in a
very primitive way I wouldn't be
surprised if that was our stupid-ass
brains those fools already explained to
us look you stupid [ __ ] humans we
[ __ ] made you guys okay and we're
like I don't go with the hell you say
and and then we became who we are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]